in March as the novel coronavirus spread
rapidly across the United States
testing was lacking while there were
many problems one simple one with a lack
of test swaps we've heard numbers
upwards of 10 million swabs per day are
needed right now in addition to what's
already supplied just for the United
States so as hospitals started to doing
all the swabbing they just couldn't get
enough swabs and testing crawled to a
halt traditional methods of
manufacturing work great in normal times
but a pandemic is not normal times one
of the big manufacturers of swabs is
based in northern Italy a region that
had been heavily impacted by the corona
virus the Air Force ferried swatch from
Italy there's one company called copan
where most swabs are made and tried to
get as many as we could bring back as
the virus spread rapidly demand for
testing in the US had so overwhelmed
supply that even people with symptoms of
cope at 19 could not get tested that
also meant that no one really knew how
many people had the virus or what the
safe packs to open the economy might
look like we still have millions of
people that need to be tested and so we
can't wait we have to use these as a
tool to be able to judge when is it safe
to bring people back traditional
manufacturing moves slowly so a new
industry has been tackling the shortage
3d printing many people still think of
3d printers is novelty items from the
early demonstrations at electronics
conventions but while 3d printing is
still just a sliver of all manufacturing
industrial 3d printers already turn out
everything from airplane parts to dental
aligners with all but non-essential
manufacturers closed during the crisis
many of these printers were now
available to print items that are
essential like nasal swallows so could
3d printing meet the demand
on the west coast 3d printing unicorn
carbon which in normal times is best
known for making missiles for Adidas
started thinking about how its
technology could help it focused on both
tests wads and face shields it was
really a very quick pivot in terms of
really focusing on the needs we went
through ten iterations of design on
swabs within a week we were able to
partner with Stanford University
you know locally and then Beth Israel
Deaconess in Boston and get clinical
feedback on these within a couple of
days and working with a partner
resolution medical who is a medical
manufacturer right and working with our
dental partners who have a resident
that's been approved by the FDA so it
all came together very quickly through a
network on the East Coast
3d printing unicorn form labs founded by
a group of MIT engineers also design
test swabs we have a lot of customers
who are in health care they begin
reaching out to us and saying hey we
think we can use your printers to fight
COBIT by making these parts that are in
short supply those users were at a
couple of hospitals one the University
of South Florida and another one was
northwell health in New York and they
had developed these printed swabs and
they asked for our help for producing
more and for kind of refining the design
and making sure they work well so I
would say a lot of it was coming from
our user is sort of telling us how we
can contribute to the fight HP origin
desktop metal and other 3d printing
companies were all working on this
effort to ramp up test swabs as
different manufacturers started
designing and testing their own swabs
ideas proliferated what should the tip
of the swab look like to grab a big
enough sample how should the neck of it
operate to make it as comfortable as
possible for the patient or you might
think a test swab is just a glorified
q-tip these medical devices are more
complex than you might think
it has a very rigid handle for the
clinician to be able to grasp it there's
a break point where the handle breaks
off into the vial and you don't want it
to break when it's being used on a
patient and then it has a long flexible
neck that allows the tip to navigate
through the nose and into the back of
the throat and then finally it has a
lattice tip that replaces the
traditional flock brush that you'd get
on a swab and so we were able to create
more than 20 completely different
designs of parallel 3d print them all at
once sent them to the clinicians and
they chose the most promising design
probably for the first swab we printed
until they had patient trials was like
two weeks or less normally a product
like this actually doesn't require any
kind of FDA approval it requires the
manufacturer to take on the burden of
testing and verifying the product but
the FDA has gotten involved knowing that
this is like an unusual situation and to
help things move more quickly one
advantage of 3d printing is that the
swabs themselves can be produced in bulk
at a medical manufacturing facility
where the digital design file can be
passed off to a hospital that has its
own fleet of printers to print on demand
supplies have been terribly disrupted
based on this virus and so really how do
we enable local supplies became a
rallying point we had a lot of the
elements already in place we had
printers in hospitals we had
biocompatible materials that we produce
in our own facility it kind of feels
like we were already set up to do
exactly this thing form Labs is in a lot
of hospitals which meant that they were
more accessible so if we were able to
come up with something
that could be used then we could
distribute that amongst some of the
network of the 3d medical teams and that
way it could help a lot of hospitals
immediately by doing that then we
actually could reach more of a target
audience so that we could get these out
to help as many people as possible but
don't do this at home
unlike basic cloth masks where there's
little danger of doing it wrong nasal
test swabs are medical devices that need
to be made by qualified medical
lecturers we know that there are a lot
of hobbyists out there who want to help
but we've had to explain this is a
medical device being used for
Diagnostics
it can't be printed by just anyone we
don't want people to get in trouble but
the biggest thing is we don't want
people to have tests that are not vetted
that I've not been validated and then
that be used as public health
information and so we're doing that
under the practice of medicine Rick
fuller co-founder and CEO of desktop
metal whose company makes metal 3d
printers had an idea to bring together
the normally competitive industry into a
loose coalition he started organizing a
group of CEOs and he set up a website
printed Suave's org to act as a
clearinghouse for the effort in a period
of about three or four days we had two
dozen companies that had the capability
to make product at scale one hundred
plus people worked throughout those
companies to try to make these
prototypes get them tested out of that
five products came out that meet all the
requirements and those are now in
production and volume and so all of this
stuff is happening in record time and we
sort of put our egos aside and decided
that you know as an industry we can
provide millions of these swabs per week
and scale to tens of millions I don't
think there's ever been a time where
like the CEOs of so many direct
competitors at least in our field were
together on calls and and talking about
how to make progress on a common problem
wide scale testing will be needed in
order to safely reopen the economy and
continue testing will be required for
long after that that means that even as
other methods of producing test swabs
come online and the existing
manufacturers of them ramp up their own
capacity there's likely to be demand for
the 3d printed versions for some time
3d printing capabilities during the
crisis could also prove to be a turning
point for that industry what I'm excited
about is that we started this situation
with a shortage of swabs and we probably
will end up with an export product I
think they'll be
you know continued interest in 3d
printing I think some healthcare
providers would even start to see them
as a necessary piece of equipment almost
like a backup generator that you know
that a hospital would have it's gonna
it's going to make a big impact continue
printing we're going to come out of this
the world's going to be different and I
think it's up to us to really create
that new trajectory not only for a
company like carbon but for the 3d
printing industry so I think I look at
it as an opportunity for us to really
create a very different future
[Music]